everybody and welcome back to parka Tex
campaign mode and today I clicked on the
airplane so that's still circling around
but today I'll be working on Coral
caldera which is one of the scenarios
which I made and it's over here in coral
island and basically this story is that
some rich guy managed to purchase the
island and wants to turn it into a theme
park so this is the first out of many
island scenarios I think in the game if
I remember correctly I can already see a
bit more of an archipelago forming over
here but it'll be a bit of a theme I
think with this being the first and one
with the largest amount of space in
terms of land I think it's quite a large
empty map and you can really do a lot of
things with this island so it's been
really interesting for me to see what
people have been doing to this scenario
I've seen lots of people building
actually not that many people but my
original intention was for instance to
give you some space to maybe build a
coaster all around the park or just
stick to the valley inside the island
lots of interesting ways in which you
can use the natural terrain which you
have in the scenario but to be quite
honest I didn't really think about how I
would take all the scenario myself what
I do know though is that it has a bit of
a tropical theme to it as you can see so
I do want to stick to that and the goals
are pretty simple so there shouldn't be
too much of a challenge unless the
weather or the amount of guests that
we're gonna be generating are gonna be
additional challenges so without further
ado let's get into the scenario and see
what we can make of it so the map itself
is really quite simple it's just a round
shaped caldera with some hills on the
sides and then an empty plane in the
middle because essentially a caldera is
just a crater left behind by a volcano
and in this case in this case it's one
that's in the middle of the sea I was
inspired by Okajima in Japan which
funnily enough is part of the Tokyo
metropolis but it's far out from Japan
actually but yeah it's just a really
beautiful island and I thought it'd be
an interesting setting for a scenario
there really isn't too much else on this
we have a little boat house over here
which is
where people are arriving so normally
you'd have a guest spawnpoint someone on
the edge of the map but obviously since
this is an island they're coming from
some kind of building in this case where
ideally the boats would be arriving and
then there's a little lighthouse on the
edge of the island as well because I
couldn't stop myself from building that
but yeah the the map itself as in the
actual park borders that you get is all
empty and yeah basically very good land
to build whatever you want to you know
whatever theme you want to see yeah
without further ado let's get started
all right now the selection of rides
that we get from the start is extremely
limited so I will be doing some research
but for now there's not a lot of stuff
that I can work with and I wanted to
start off with some kind of roller
coaster with a decent intensity rating
to at least attract some guests into the
park and give them something to do and
pretty much the only thing I could do
anything with is the wild mouse coaster
and because I didn't want to make a
standard wild mouse for the third time
in a row I decided to build something a
little bit like a girl our bobsled
coaster and for the uninitiated a
bobsled coaster is not as the name
suggests an actual bobsled coaster but
it's a sort of variation on the wild
mouse by girl hour which has more banked
turns and much more interesting layouts
I think with airtime Hills and sort of
spread out layouts a really interesting
coaster type and definitely one of my
favorites when it comes to really small
coasters so that's the kind of thing
that I decided to build over here as you
can see that it has some of the typical
characteristics of a wild mouse coaster
like the tight hairpin turns and many
block breaks along the the ride and
those small cards but at the same time
you get these airtime Hills like over
here and I was trying to figure out how
to get back to the station with an
interesting track and what kind of brake
run I had to build to actually be able
to go over some of the earlier parts of
the track and I also discovered and this
I think is not supposed to be in the
game that with the new autocomplete
feature you can make
brakes that have like a slope going up
and down which I don't think you're
supposed to be able to build those kinds
of things but that said I'm also not
complaining because it's pretty awesome
actually that stuff actually has a lot
of users but yeah and eventually I
figured out how to get back into the
station these coasters typically end
with a little helix and the only real
problem that I ran into is that the wild
mouse coaster in game because it is a
wild mouse coaster I'm not based on the
girl our bobsled it doesn't allow for a
lot of banking so I had to make sure
that the curves then I did take and
wanted to Bank are somewhat slow so I'm
sort of trying to keep that in mind with
the layouts the maximum degree of
banking on this coaster I think is 15
percent something like that so really
not as much as the real-life girl or
bobsled coaster so there's a bit of a
difference there in any case I thought
the station building for this coaster
would be a really interesting sort of
entrance building it's not quite an
endurance building because obviously the
people are already in the park but it's
a nice sort of symmetrical shape to have
the people go through some kind of
building before they really enter the
rest of the park and it's also a good
time to sort of test the theme that I
wanted to try for this park because even
though it's based on a Japanese island
it doesn't really have a Japanese theme
and I figured it might be fun to try a
sort of Polynesian style theme if you've
been familiar with my koala Beach series
in planet coaster with the ladies Einar
and Corrales and Rudy Ren Kemal the
style is very similar to that I think
mostly inspired actually by that series
so lots of thatched roofs and dark
wooden pillar constructions and a very
tropical atmosphere overall and I think
it works out pretty well actually with
the elements in the game there isn't
really strictly any Polynesian theming
in park attacks but just because you're
able to recolor and sort of repurpose so
many items so much I think it's pretty
easy to do this kind of thing if you
just get the right roof color
get the right color for the wooden
pillars and just kind of go from there
so yeah
essentially these are all just thatched
roofs being held up by simple wooden
framework I'm doing the same sort of
thing as I did with the Western map in
terms of letting the pillars stake outs
from the roof a little bit and having
them be a little bit more toward the
middle of a tile to make it look as if
the roof is really an overhanging roof
when really all of them are perfectly
placed on the grid so I think that same
style works out quite nicely over here
as well at first I wanted to try to make
this a little bit more inspired by
Indonesian theming but then again I feel
like the last time when Dutch people try
to force Indonesian architecture into
some kind of Indonesian setting that
didn't really work out very well to say
the least and yeah in my case I couldn't
really figure out anything quite with
the scenery pieces either so I'm sort of
keeping it know generically tropical and
that kind of whole part of the world so
it's not really referring to any kind of
particular country or anything I did
like the sort of tunnel that we've got
going there from the entrance of the
park where you have a sort of
overhanging roof with some of those more
hangers style roofs which even though
they're metal plates if you recolor them
to a brown color I think it looks pretty
good as a sort of wooden or maybe even
bamboo sort of texture and because these
roofs can be placed off-grid it's
actually a really good piece for
overhanging roofs so that's definitely
something to remember and also a little
trick that I will be doing again at some
later point in the scenario or some
future scenarios as well now as for the
rock work and the foliage and all of
that it's pretty similar to what I've
been doing so far but I definitely want
to focus more on foliage you know the
more tropical you go I feel the more
foliage you generally gets so I'm gonna
put a lot of shrubbery in this Park and
a lot of very green shrubbery on a bunch
of flowers and some brownish rocks I'm
not entirely sure but I think it should
work out with the sort of theme of this
being
volcano I hope it's at least the den
poel que no because the the real caldera
that this is based on is actually still
an active volcano and I don't know if
building a theme park inside of an
active volcano is the best idea but then
again I feel I think that thing hasn't
exploded in over 200 years so that's
that's decent I guess but yeah I'm just
gonna assume that this caldera is not
gonna erupt anytime soon so moving into
the rest of the park I don't really have
any good coasters to build I have the
junior coaster but God knows I've been
building that one for every single
episode so I'm gonna stay off that one
for today so I'm just gonna build a few
flat rides here in the meantime while we
get some more stuff in research
hopefully and just get a good selection
of rides before I'm able to open the
park and just kind of see what the
guests think of it because I do always
want to get a pretty good start for the
park before I actually open it to the
guests and hey if I work really hard I
might even be able to reach that goal of
doing everything with in year two but
probably not so here it goes for the the
wave swing and I don't actually know
chair swing I should say I don't
actually know what the thing is called
in game but you know what right this is
everybody knows this ride and it's it's
just a nice sort of entrance run I think
this is one of those rides that you
really want to put on display that's why
I put it on half a tile Heights from the
pots just because it's it's one of those
rights which are really nice to look at
at least I always like looking at these
rides I think it's similar to the
carousel for instance very much it's
sort of part of the scenery as much as
it is a ride so over here I think it's
time for a food courts and this Park is
a little bit different from a lot of the
other parks there isn't really any kind
of direct connection to the Depot but
there is already a pre-built transport
tube going into the park for all kinds
of deliveries and trash so I'm just
gonna connect to that and build my food
courts over here
there should be enough space behind this
whole place to build some backstage
areas with a small extra Depot and a
staff room so that's pretty much what
I'm gonna do I also quite like the
colors on the umbrellas I don't know it
feels pretty tropical just because of
the settings because otherwise I feel
like green and red would be extremely
Christmassy but yeah I'm also trying to
keep very much a sort of color scheme a
very warm colors so green and red and
orange and all of those kinds of colors
I think should work out pretty well for
this scenario so here we go with a
enterprise ride which is honestly one of
my favorite flat rides I really like
these things so I feel like whenever I
have one of them in a scenario might as
well place it it's a pretty good ride
from a game perspective as well pretty
high intensity definitely one of the
better flat rides that gets and a good
way to make the people who want intense
rides not so angry so always good to
have one of these in your Park and it's
same here I didn't want to change the
color scheme a little bit to some warmer
colors and make it quite bright and
vibrance you know this is very tropical
map so might as well keep the colors
oversaturated I think and over here it's
time for the real food courts and
fittingly we have some Chinese food
which I guess you know we're sort of in
an Asian area so that's gonna have to do
unfortunately and some bubble tea for
all of you hipsters out there but hey
it's gonna keep guests hydrated and not
too hungry so that's gonna do and then
some umbrellas because even though I
haven't unpause the game yet I feel like
it might be getting pretty rainy at some
point I also just noticed it's it's 30
degrees in the park so it really is a
very warm climate in here so I think
that the at the very least the theme
that I'm going for really fits the area
where it might be in real life so yeah
here we go
just the simple food courts with a few
stalls not too special really and at the
back of this there is this sort of empty
space with a lot of
space for some backstage areas but I'll
be coming back to that later for now I
wanted to add one more ride before we go
into well before we go into a little bit
of it at the test of the park and open
it up to guests and it's gonna be a
carousel I just wanted to finish the
pathways over here real quickly give
them a little bit more detail before I
moved into that part but yeah I wanted
to place a carousel over here as a
another sort of ride to car can't really
add a sort of central position in the
park and I'm not quite sure what I'm
gonna do around this I want to have more
sort of rides that weave together and
have interaction with each other but so
far I pretty much just have flat rides
and then I have the e junior coaster
laughs but you know I don't really want
to do anything with that yet so I'm not
quite sure how much I'm going to expand
I might need to do more research before
I expand into the park much more because
I want to avoid you know making the park
just a a plane with a bunch of flat
rides in it you know that can work and
it can look nice if you add a lot of
detail but I'd like to make it a little
bit more interesting give it some more
depth and then over here just to fill up
this space and an extra building this is
going to be a small toilet building and
it's also gonna have a vending machine
because we're well actually we're not
too far away from the food courts but
might as well put vending machines
everywhere I think you know the more I'm
looking at the chair swing the more I'm
feeling like I might make it green I'm
not sure like maybe something like
turquoise or something like that I just
feel like the blue is a little bit too
cold for the pike but I'll think about
that later colour schemes are just one
of these things where you can always
sort of keep working on its and keep
changing little things until it's
exactly the way you want it to be anyway
I decided to move into this little
corner here build a small Hut's or
something I don't know I didn't quite
know what to really do with it I just
felt like I needed some kind of small
building there to counteract the the
toilets and vending machine building and
get some more thatch roofs up in here
because these roofs are
looking pretty nice even though they're
just standard roofs with a sort of tacky
color to them it works out surprisingly
well I think so that's pretty much the
basic structure of the park so far not
quite sure how I'm going to expand it
from here but it should be pretty much
functional especially now that we
finally have the star room or the staff
room there we go and the depot
everything should be getting pretty
functional and now it's just time to
start on pausing the game and see if
this part can actually run some profits
or if I'm gonna have to take another
loan and got more stuff to actually fix
it I'm not quite sure but we'll see how
that works out alright so let's go to a
quick real time section all right I
think it's good that I'm doing this
overview because I decided to redo a few
things about the wild mouse coaster here
so I added an extra blog break over here
which used to be a little dip basically
and added two extra cars onto the
circuit so I could add one extra car
because there's an extra block break but
really the problem that I was running
into is that because the length of the
blocks was uneven so the final block
over here is much longer in duration and
the other blocks the cars would always
get stuck on this block break over here
because there it would always take so
long for the next car to finish this
whole block over here that they'd have
to wait so that was a bit of a problem
like really you always have to make sure
that all of your block sections are at
least somewhat similar in length or you
get cars that get stuck on block brakes
so that was basically the problem and
because of that and the fact that I have
to block brakes at the end I could add
two more cars and now it's actually a
perfectly efficient and super smoothly
running machine so you'll be able to
tell that there's always one car on the
block brakes over here waiting for the
station to empty out and then if we hide
the scenery like this you can see that
there's always one car unloading and one
car loading so that's pretty much the
maximum efficiency you can get and as
soon as another car enters the block
brakes over here the next car can move
into the station again
so I don't think I could make this much
more efficient it actually works really
well this way and the throughput is
pretty amazing and the profits
I think this dip is right around the
time where I closed it down to work and
it's for a little bit so that's why the
revenue over here is lower for these
months but you can pretty much see that
after changing it the revenue is higher
than it used to be so this turned out to
be sort of a an accidental little
scientific experiment to see how much
you know more money you can make just by
making your block sections more
efficient so that's one thing other than
that's I'm not really running into too
many problems just some vandalism issues
again as always there's a lot of
vandalism it's not really too bad but
it's definitely to the extent where I
feel like an extra security and an extra
mechanic guy are gonna be necessary and
that aside I think it's again partly
because there's not a great selection of
rides I should probably focus a little
bit more on intense rides again but that
shouldn't be too much of a concern I
think so far I'm doing pretty well I
think and I decided to research roller
coasters so we have a little bit more
but to be honest the inverted coaster
isn't exactly what I was looking for and
the powered coaster isn't exactly my
favorites I still have the extra twister
flat ride which I could put somewhere so
that helps and a pirate ship somewhere
but in terms of the calm rides there's
not too much left either so yeah I'm
pretty limited when it comes to the
kinds of rides that I'll be able to
build but um I mean I'll see what I can
do with it I don't think I'm gonna make
the optional goal of doing it within
within a year - that's definitely not
gonna happen I do want to make the most
of the park here but ya doing pretty
well so let's start working on some
stuff again alright so I decided to give
myself the challenge of building a bnm
inverted coaster in the end which is a
little bit more expensive and difficult
to build than the other coasters but I
think it's also much more rewarding and
I'm going for a sort of terrain
conforming coaster very
heavily inspired by nemesis in Alton
Towers just because I think that works
really nicely with the natural terrain
of the caldera that we have over here
where the lift Hill just sort of follows
the hill and then you kind of come down
from there but then there's also the
sort of low-lying area next to the
station where you're going through all
of the bigger inversions and when I say
that it's a bit more of a rewarding
coaster I think there's a bit of a risk
attached to it as well that being that I
ended up spending quite a lot of time
trying to get the layouts to be right
especially because this space over here
is really limited so answer you shuffle
things around every now and then to make
sure that stuff would actually fit so
you'll see me you know I have a lot of
sections where I just can't really
figure out how to work my way around the
elements and then just kind of delete
some stuff or move the entire coaster
around until it works I've gotten some
comments about you know how it looks as
if I do everything very easily and right
away on the time-lapse without really
having to think much about it but
sometimes that isn't really the case as
is over here and I think it took quite a
bit of trial and error to get those
layouts to be right but yeah in the in
the general spirits of Nemesis I wanted
to have a similar feeling layouts very
serene conforming layouts beginning with
a corkscrew and then sort of meandering
down the hill into a zero-g roll which
up until that point is very much sort of
similar layouts to Nemesis and then it
does a bunch of stuff and ends with a
loop somewhere near the end of the track
but sort of getting these elements II in
the right order was a bit of a challenge
so I kept trying to fit a zero-g roll
rights behind the station for a while
but in the end I figured it might be
better to have it go over the station
and sort of go into the other direction
because this opens up a little bit more
space and you know allows me to also
actually build some paths and some cues
which are going to be necessary as well
and then finally sort of curve back with
this helix into the other area for a
while I was thinking that it might be
possible to go even
lower than the other sections and sort
of have the loop somewhere near the
station low below the ground but really
that didn't end up working all too well
the space over here is super limited and
there's also the lake nearby and I
didn't want to create a deep canyon
right next to the lake because that I
don't know might look a little bit weird
so that this plan didn't really end up
working after all because there's just
not really enough space to make this
kind of thing work nevermind that I have
to get back to this station as well and
I would have no idea how to get back to
the station from there so I ended up
sort of choosing a slightly different
routes just pretty much going along the
same sort of straight axis to the back
of the park and this means that I am
using up a lot of space in the park so
this definitely narrows down the amount
of things that I can still do but at the
same time it works out so much better
for the inverts it's coasters so I think
it's probably for the best to build the
layout like this and again I'm using
this trick a lot where you sort of
disconnect some track pieces and then
reconnect them in a single piece using
the auto connect feature to make things
more smooth and I think this is
especially useful when you're trying to
you know transition between two curves
and maybe different heights so you can
get a sort of smooth banking transition
but also very handy at the end of the
track for instance what it's actually
supposed to be for where you connect up
to the brake run which might be a little
bit lower than the track section that
you're trying to connect to it so
all-around super handy trick and I also
have to say I've gotten some questions
if I want to make a sort of parka text
coaster eCollege is similar to planet
coaster college about the coaster
builder and I don't know how much I've
actually said about this in videos but
I've been thinking about this for sure
so I would like to do this sometime soon
it's not gonna be a very complicated
video I think since really the coaster
builder is pretty easy to understand so
I'm gonna keep it quite simple I should
also say I know a dear friend of mine
who's also been doing something similar
so once the time comes I'll also link
his
description that so far I'm gonna keep
that one a secret until I really work
out what I'm gonna do with my video but
yeah I'm gonna do something like that
for sure and one of my major talking
points is definitely going to be you
know how this sort of Otto connects
feature can help you build some slightly
smoother coasters or get you out of a
pinch if you've got you know if you've
got your coaster stuck somewhere anyway
let's try to you know get up to speed
with the video again so I've built a
small teacups ride over there I'm
definitely gonna want to look at the
color scheme again because it's it's
still pink and blue and it doesn't
really fit the theme too much but yeah
it's a flat ride that fits really well
over there it sort of rounds up this
corner of the park gives you something
else to go to this corner of the park
for and it's something under a roof as
well which is always fun to build and
pretty handy and then the station
building has the exits coming out over
here which I know is a grave sin because
the exit is much more obvious than the
entrance but I just wanted to have a
wide wooden bridge sort of go over that
Valley where the coaster dives
underneath it and then have the station
right next to it which is you know oh
woah-oh mode I just hit my pop filter I
hope you didn't hear too much about that
but uh it's always fun to sort of have
things go on top of each other and
underneath each other definitely
something I liked doing a lot in
bellicose Tycoon you know the more you
can get coaster track and paths and all
kinds of scenery to sort of be layered
and stacked on top of each other it just
makes stuff more interesting then if
everything were just on a single flats
one dimensional plane so I don't know I
just like doing stuff like that so
there's the bridge pretty nice with the
coaster going underneath it but also
above it with the station right next to
it so that's that's pretty much what
I've run out of a coaster in park
attacks and the rest of the scenery is
all going to be quite simple I'm not
going to do too much just yet because I
do wanna give a bit of a real-time
updates very soon again but just once we
finish off the queue and add a bit of
scenery to it so the queue itself is
pretty simple not really
too many no cattle pens or anything like
that it's just of making its way through
the landscape and having a lot of in or
interaction with the coaster track as
well which is always nice and then
there's just some path elements just to
fill up this space because it's quite
open and there's not really enough space
to put anything in particular like a
ride or some stalls or anything like
that so I'm just gonna you know add
decorations until it's all filled up
sometimes you can really just add a
small pavilion with some benches
underneath it or something like that
it's something that quite a lot of real
life theme parks will have as well and
it's just a really good way to fill up
the empty little spaces that you might
have scattered around your park so yeah
that's basically it when it comes to
that and then with some final bits of
foliage we arrived and a quick real-time
overview I know show you how
everything's working all right so I just
completed the goal of having 400 park
tickets sold so that's really nice so
now if all is well I should have the
steel coaster over here and there we go
that's pretty awesome and the rest of
these coasters are still the same I'm
researching thrill rides again because I
don't think I'll really need more
coasters I can probably finish it with
well the steel coaster I suppose or
maybe a small powered coaster after all
but I like to focus on the thrill rides
instead because if I just keep this park
going I'll get to eight hundred guests
eventually anyway so that shouldn't be
too much of concern and also I just saw
that I am getting the topple towers
which is a super interesting flat ride I
really like these things they're really
rare in the real world
they're a bit uncomfortable definitely
one of the weirdest flat rides that I've
ever been on but I know they're really
interesting it's cool to see them in the
game you'll see them in a little bit
also I got a comments on the last video
that I should probably give some well
not POVs of the coasters but at least
follow them from the sort of off topic
or the the override perspective that you
get in the game so I think that's a
really cool idea it's nice to do that
real quick I'm gonna have to remove that
three actually I do
realize some of these trees it doesn't
really have much of a hitbox for so it
can you know run into stuff and it was
definitely hitting that tree which might
be a little bit uncomfortable for people
riding a coaster but yeah here we go you
do have that sort of camera which can
follow the coaster along and again like
I said earlier I don't really uh that
transition is so smooth
I don't really that one too but yeah I
don't really wants to do any real on
right POVs which you can do with mods
because I feel it kind of breaks the
isometric immersion perspective of the
game and god there's more trees to fix
up there let's get out of here and
remove some of these trees because
that's definitely not a great thing so
this one and then yeah these trees over
here that's that's definitely a problem
alright I think the rest it's more or
less fine maybe this just in case I'll
definitely do more scenery here and
there once you know this this whole area
around it is finished the queue still
needs some coverings and swell and you
know other kinds of little details
scattered around but the basics are here
and you know for the hell of it
let's just follow this thing along as
well and I'm not quite sure what terrain
the thing chooses yeah it's just kind of
going around
alright let's follow this this train or
car I should really say see I hear the
people are happily going along the track
and as you can see it's not really the
most smooth thing ever
the university coaster is definitely a
lot smoother but I think it works
alright
it's a wild mouse coaster after all and
into the airtime Hills which are my
favorite parts and in real life on these
coasters as well they're really fun I
think their heads bumped into the
catwalks but whatever I'm gonna keep
those around they look way too nice but
yeah you can see that at this point
there should definitely be more banking
but for that as well I'm just gonna
forget about it and there we go that
nice little drop down into the station
very subtle but I really like it
that's super cool it's also nice how
like smoothly you sort of move in
out of these views because it just kind
of sticks to a car but as soon as you
scroll out and move around you get
snapped out of that sort of position so
pretty cool overall I am quite happy
with how the park is turning out so far
and honestly I'm not too sure what else
I could really build I'm already running
out of space so I'm probably gonna maybe
try to fit in a small flat right over
here and I've already tried to measure
that out but it doesn't really work out
too well maybe a twister might work but
then I need to get some kind of one tile
path that sort of no narrowly work wraps
itself around the flat right so that
might not work out too well but I
definitely want to loop around to this
side of the lake and maybe have a small
water ride or some flat rides along this
side and if there is money and time and
space for another roller coaster I could
probably build a station over here and
see wherever that thing is going but
that said I'm not sure if I can really
you know build a roller coaster around
the entire island and to be fair that
would also be a little bit ridiculous
you know it wouldn't be quite realistic
and I do like to keep these parks at
least somewhat realistic but that said
another terrain conforming coaster that
sort of wraps itself around these hills
would be really cool as well
so let's move on and go back into the
time-lapse all right so forget about the
idea of building a train conforming
coaster that didn't really work out too
well but there's still plenty of
interesting flat rights to stay around
for I think and one of them is the
topple tower over here so I've mentioned
this before and it is a really kind of a
weird flat ride there's nothing that
kind of does the same thing basically
what it does it just raises you to the
top of that tower and then the tower
starts wiggling back and forth and
rotating it's a very strange experience
but it basically just pushes you into
the overhead restraints that you get
which is a little bit uncomfortable
definitely for me being a man down there
but it's it's very interesting it's a
super unique ride and you don't see too
many of them in the world so it's cool
to see it in the game as well so I'm
building this alongside the water area
because what I did notice for the one
that
which is I forgot the name of the park
but it's the same park where you have be
rotten in Denmark but the way that you
you sort of built these things in a nice
way I suppose is by having some kind of
area around it which is nice to sort of
you know fall towards so I know the one
in Denmark had some water around it and
some fountains there that you would sort
of you know go down and then be raised
up again when you're almost getting
there not quite but it's at least an
interesting sort of surrounding to tap
into so that's that right and then we
have the good old trusty twister over
here on the side as well and that's a
ride you can always count on it's always
pretty cheap and pretty small and it
just fits into every single Park so
there's no reason not to build it really
and in this case it fills in the space
between the topple tower and the
inverted coaster quite nicely and for
the rest of this place I didn't really
want to build any more flat rides I
definitely wanted to have some sort of a
more transitional area with some toilets
and a bit of an outlook over the pond
that we have over here I don't know if
you can really call it a lake it's
pretty small I suppose but yeah it's a
sort of relaxing back parts area of the
park with mostly just benches I am
placing a lot of tall fences over here
because again it's super close to the
inverted coaster and I wouldn't want
anybody to jump over the fences and try
to pick up a hat or something and get
decapitated by the coaster so putting
quite a tall fence over there yeah that
that actually happened and remember at
some points with Batman the ride which
is super tragic and part of that is the
reason why there are such tall fences
very often where you get close to
coaster tracks
I know nemesis actually no not nemesis
nemesis actually as well as super tall
fences around the Q line etc but black
mamba in Fantasia land I also remember
for being one of these bnm inverts with
really tall fences and very good you
know protection everywhere and it's
nearly impossible to get anywhere near
the coaster in that coaster even though
the queue line and the paths get super
close to the layouts
so especially for bnm inverts that's
something that I like to keep in mind
because I don't know these colors are
low-key dangerous from an override
perspective now over here I am building
a small sort of Bally like temple based
on these Indonesian temples that you
find in Bali and I have to be completely
honest I'm not an expert when it comes
to this kind of architecture and also we
don't really have you know the pieces
that you need to make this kind of thing
but just stacking a bunch of triangles
with the right shape and the right shade
of brown on top of each other with a few
details here and there I think more or
less works and it gets the idea across
these things kind of look like pagodas
but they're more made out of bamboo I
believe they are in any case I'm just
sort of trying to recreate the shape I
definitely want to go there one day I
have never been to Indonesia and I would
definitely love to visit it one day but
yeah just building this over here
because I think it fits really well I
know I've said before that I might put a
flat right in this space but that really
didn't work out that was too complicated
of a puzzle to try and solve and it
really wouldn't make too much sense
either I think this is pretty good place
for just some sort of scenery backdrop
and some places where you can just sit
on a bench and sit back and look at the
roller coasters or something like that
so making this more into a sort of
scenic overlook parts of the park and
then over here on this corner which is
more or less empty I think this is a
good space for some flat rides so I put
the topspin over there so that'll be a
pretty good start I'm not really going
to add too much scenery to this top spin
compared to some of the other top spins
of belts just a very simple log bank
drop to the same thing as I did with the
Western I think I built the top spin
there actually I didn't but doing the
same sort of you know log wall made out
of separate pillars just with a
different type of wood this time and
then some very basic decorations around
it I think with some of the freedom that
you get in terms of where you put
scenery pieces it is very possible to
sort of dress up flat rides
in ways in which you want to sort of add
some things here in there so I'm just
keeping it very simple here but
definitely with some of the pillar
pieces and some of the basic shapes that
we get you can actually do a lot of
experimentation with you know giving
flat rides a different skin and over
here I think it's called the top scan
but I'm actually not entirely sure let
me look up what that thing is calling
again
but yeah I'm putting up the star shape
that's it actually the star shape ride
which is one of those things which I've
personally never been on because of also
I've always [ __ ] down on these things
and I should definitely go on one of
these one day but yeah it's this this
thing that goes upside down and the
seats are rotating and the seats are
also on a rotating circle it's one of
these things with so many moving parts
that I'm just afraid that it would make
me super nauseous but from a game
perspective it has a high intensity
rating and the pretty high excitement
rating and nausea rating as well so it's
pretty good for the park and honestly at
this point I'm just trying to fill in
stuff because really if I just keep the
park running I'm going to get the 800
tickets sold pretty soon and the guests
are more than happy with the park so
that'll be fine I just want to make sure
that I'm filling up all of the parts of
the caldera and you know getting a
decent amount of rides in the park and I
think with the amount of flat rides that
I have right now and the amount of
coasters it's pretty much fine another
reason that I didn't want to build
another coaster is that I felt like for
the size of the park two coasters is
pretty much all you need so you know
there's a family coaster and there's a
more intense coaster and we don't really
need too much else considering how small
the park is after all since I haven't
really gone out of the caldera
and finally there's a bunch of stuff
that I just want to slightly improve and
I forgot to record some things here so
I'm gonna have to put some commentary
over some things that I don't show yet
but I'll show that in a quick real-time
section as well so I decided to dress up
the queue a little bit more for the
inverted coaster and also add some
catwalks to it and I'm not going to add
catwalks through every coaster that I do
but for some of the more themed ones
where you can sort of get a catwalk that
fits the theme as well like over here
with the sort of bamboo and wooden
planks look of the coaster I think that
works out quite alright okay so let's go
back to a real-time overview and there
we go with its the park and it's working
pretty alright I would say I'm having
more stuff than I used to for the
preview scenarios but even still I think
I could use a bit more stuff but overall
looks like it's fine no offend ilysm or
anything like that
some of the rides are making crazy money
like the inverted coaster is looking
like the most profitable coaster of the
entire playthrough so far and the little
right over here is not doing too badly I
do and then all of the flat rides are
pretty much fine as well and at the
moment we can't look at the top of tower
yet because it's still waiting to load
new people but it's looking absolutely
insane
so just a little bit more until we
actually get the goal and until we get
the next scenario and oh god we're gonna
get this in the rain I suppose
so it's interesting how many things
actually break down in the rain so some
of the smaller rides some of the more
gentle writes and less tall rides will
still be functioning but then all of the
tall stuff breaks down all right so
there we go
we did it we didn't do it in year two
but year three is actually not too bad
considering I think I completed the last
scenario in the year six or seven so I
guess I'm improving and we're gonna wait
for this thing but before we do that I
kind of feel like I want to see the
inverted coaster one more time and just
quickly checking if I didn't forget any
lighting anywhere no the entire park is
lit up that's good alright so yeah just
because I really like it
I'm just gonna follow along with this
coaster one more time let's take a
different perspective than I've been in
that perspective for quite a while now
alright let's follow this thing around
so not every part of the track is quite
smooth I also made some slight
adjustments off screen as well so for
this turn over here which is going
through I increase the banking a little
bit to make it a little bit more like a
mini Immelman I don't know what
phantasialand calls their inversion on
black mamba but it's a little bit more
like that elements at the start of Black
Mamba and this transition is just so
incredibly smooth I really really like
the new autocomplete feature and then
through the loop it's not super fast but
I think the speed is generally quite
realistic at least more realistic than
the little wild mouse coaster over there
because that thing is actually quite
fast and let's have this thing do its
thing alright get on people so yeah this
this thing is just so strange you get on
at the bottom here so it's kind of
almost looking like a super wide drop
tower if you will and then it also does
the same thing where it goes up and it
starts rotating but then the tower
itself with that massive counterweight
just starts toppling back and forth
which is uh it must be an engineering
feat honestly these things are really
impressive when it comes to the
technical perspective I would say but
yeah really cool things but if you're at
the bottom of one of these rotations
then you're hanging into those
restraints like crazy super weird so
we've got that I've got a pretty bad
framerate I should also say honestly
it's I do notice it's getting a little
bit less good because of the recording
but at this point I'm honestly noticing
a leg or a slight frame rates rope I
should say myself as well and this park
has a lot of foliage and stuff like that
so it's definitely understandable and
it's not quite tipping much below 30 but
it is definitely noticeable so that's
something to keep in mind and I don't
have the best these-- I have like a gtx
970 and an i5 processor I still think
though I'm not entirely sure it might be
an i7 as well but it's something to keep
in mind if you do
and a lot of scenery into the game you
know for campaign mode it'll be more or
less fine like you might get a bit of a
framerate drop at the end of the
campaign or at the end of each map I
should say but if you're building a
really big sandbox Park I can really
imagine this being an issue so speaking
of which I've got some requests to build
a sandbox park but I have to say as long
as I'm going through the campaign mode I
don't really want to start on a campaign
or on a sandbox map so I'm gonna stick
to the campaign for now but yeah that'll
be it's for a Korell caldera I don't
think any of these coasters works really
well as blueprints considering that
they're quite terrain conforming but
I'll see if there is anything else that
I'll uploads but a it's quite a
different case from Western roundup I
think so for now let's say goodbye to
this park that should be fine five
minutes ago that's all right I didn't
really change anything and let's check
out what we've got next and I think it's
it's that big old group of tropical
islands so there we go the trophy is the
lighthouse that that's pretty fitting I
would say and then all of the clouds are
gonna clear and yeah there we go
oh no not quite it's actually different
from what I expected so we're going
through the the mystic desert and if I
remember correctly then this is yes
probably
mystic Oasis which is this is my
personal favourite scenario actually
that I've made the thing doesn't show
off and tiny there you go this is what
it gets basically the park is just a
small oasis in the middle of a desert
and then the other is no van lamps which
I mean considering you know how the the
order of the parks goes I should
probably do mystic Oasis first so yeah
next episode will be all about mistake
Oasis bye guys